good morning heck it's tuesday you have
just acquired possibly the cutest kitten
i have ever seen in my life and now all
that remains is the extremely fraught
work of naming that kitten fortunately i
am here to help now hank your kid has
already suggested several cat names
including kirker cacker and geburker all
of which are excellent cat names because
one they are unique i don't think there
are a lot of cats out there named
gerberker and two they capture both the
cuteness of the cat and the cuteness of
the namer but also any potential pet
name must first pass the test of
imagining saying it to the veterinary
clinic and i love the idea of you
calling the vet and being like hello yes
i'd like to schedule a follow-up
appointment for my kitten geburker green
now hank farbeat for me to try to
improve upon your son's near-perfect ear
for cat names but i do have some
opinions on this matter and like all
opinions valued by the social internet
they are strongly held and of dubious
quality now hank your late great cat
cameo had a perfect cat name and i'm
sure you're gonna come up with something
good but i'm a little nervous because
you once on our podcast told someone to
name their kitten like manhole cover and
that's not a good cat name so yeah i do
have some advice i guess the first
question is whether to pick a common
human name which in general i think is a
risky strategy like what if you name
your cat christopher and later develop a
best friendship with someone named
christopher but if you do pick a common
human name i think it should be as regal
and fancy as possible like instead of
just calling your cat philip you could
call it philip vii sovereign of bavaria
and god king of the lesser realms green
that's a fun one to say to the vet i
also think there are lots of good
apparel based names for cats like pants
is a great name socks is excellent
cardigan ain't bad of course you can
take this too far like ball gown green
is not a good name for a cat nor is
ralph lauren polo shirts but i get them
at the outlet so they're 60 off green it
just occurred to me this is slightly off
topic that ralph lauren's first name is
ralph
like the will ren gets so much emphasis
his name is ralph what a great name but
right back to cat names of course hank
you will consider some punny names like
holden clawfield or catnip everdeen and
you know those are high risk high reward
for me like if you miss it's very eye
rolly but if you get it just right it's
brilliant like edgar allan poe had a cat
named katarina that's a great cat name
speaking of writers quite a few of them
have named their cats after their work
like sylvia plath had a famous poem
called daddy and a cat called daddy
george bernard shaw had a cat called
pygmalion and i cannot recommend that
strategy like an absolutely remarkable
thing is a good name for a book but not
for a cat on the other hand i do think
you can get inspiration from writers
like ursula k le guin had a cat called
mother courage which is phenomenal doris
lessing had one called el magnifico
which is also top drawer but don't
follow along with all the writers like
mark twain who to be fair was never
great at titles called his cat's names
like satan and beelzebub and pestilence
i don't think you should call your cat
pestilence hank but i do think it's
worth considering a historically
resonant name like felicet which was the
name of the french cat who was the first
cat stranaut it went to space and and
then came back and then there's my
all-time favorite historical cat masak
who was nikola tesla's childhood cat as
a very small child tesla was petting the
sock and felt a shock and saw a spark
and asked his father what was going on
and his father said well that's
electricity just like the lightning that
comes in storms and little tiny tesla
was like whoa the same thing that
happened with my cat is happening in the
sky
and then he asked himself these are his
words
is nature a giant cat and in some ways
he spent the rest of his life trying to
examine that question so to summarize
hank number one name your cat whatever
you want and number two
nature is a gigantic cat i will see you
on friday